[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
family at the vineyard tell me i need to
be a little bit more patient
incentives in your new country and
everything you know i kind of
understand that more now and i hope we
can get back on a better track
sinjin and i need to breathe more and
have a little bit more fun
so we're hanging out with andrew and
james tonight
hey what's up man paul jaggerman please
my brother
this is not one of those keep them
coming type of nights
let's not work in the morning i'm chill
i'm i'm with my wife now
yeah that is crazy
i am shocked to see you i must admit
when i first met you
i thought to myself this is not gonna
work out when you split to america
i haven't told james all right well that
was a crazy story
yeah i don't unexpect the
the return flight yeah
have you guys been having fun with
sinjin's family oh my gosh i was family
bry
okay so i'll be real i got very worked
up
because nothing's been stable yet a bit
like
the way you guys met yeah the hustle you
came on to
isn't that rush like what keeps you guys
together like isn't that what drew you
to him
yeah but also so many flags back then
like all these flags that come up now
like i'm thinking like how why did i
even stay
but it was not a big deal it was not a
big deal at the time
i'll call it denial she mentioned uh the
whole time
i red flags red flags red flags
which means you saw it
you just chose not to believe it there
we go he was completely honest and
blatant with everything
you sold yourself you're married now
[Music]